quels chefs de partis est le plus
compétent selon vous de la compétence ou
de l'incompétence vous voulez dire je
réponds pas la boussole électorale vous
a questionné sur la compétence de chaque
chef de parti et vous a demandé de leur
donner une note sur 10 donnera 1,5 à
tout le monde moi ça fait marquis
simplement thomas mulcair est le chef
qui reçoit la meilleure note avec un 5,5
sur 10 gilles duceppe le seul à être
évalués par des utilisateurs québécois
seulement reçoit 4,6 il est talonné par
justin trudeau et elizabeth may stephen
harper reçoit la note la plus basse 4,2
je pense on veut parler de compétences
ces années ici plutôt que je dirais plus
l'opportunisme la boussole vous a aussi
demandé dans quelle mesure vous faites
confiance à chaque chef je pense avec
l'électorat gilles duceppe s'en estime j
pas de chat mais si j'avais un char mais
moi j'ai toujours fait les vêtements
toujours thomas mulcair et il habite
mais sont presque au coude à coude avec
respectivement une note de 5,1 et 2,5
justin trudeau à la troisième meilleure
note avec 4,7 sur 10 gilles duceppe à
3,9 et stephen harper obtient 2,9 sur 10
lors des élections fédérales de 2011
les utilisateurs de la boussole avait
également indiqué que stephen harper
était le chef le moins dignes de
confiance il ce qui n'a pas empêché les
conservateurs de former un gouvernement
majoritaire
les résultats présentés notre reportage
ont été compilées à partir d'un
échantillon de 380 3000 personnes qui
ont utilisé la boussole entre le 26 août
et le 20 septembre ici wifi depuis mai
raj qu'adam en rien